foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Petersburg and I'm sensitive tonight
what is a woman a documentary seeking to
answer the most vexing question of our
times was censored this weekend and then
explode into one of the most viewed
films of all time Matt Walsh The Man
Behind the biggest movie in the world
right now joins me live
the national Scandal over morning TV
presenters Affair enters what feels like
week seven thousand are there big
questions left to answer or is it time
to stop persecuting as some people think
Phillip Schofield I'll give my verdict
and we'll debate ITV and its toxicity
plus I'll talk to Noam Chomsky one of
the great clinical thinkers in modern
history about Ukraine Trump free speech
and the end of the world
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening mother welcome to Petersburg
center it's good to be back and it's
good but it's Pride months which of
course used to be about celebrating gay
rights and quite right too but it's now
mostly about advertising campaigns by
Brands celebrating their own
righteousness
big businesses love to Signal their
virtue in English-speaking countries
where gay rights have been hard fought
and hard earned but not so much in the
Middle East where it's often illegal and
punishable by death and with everything
from Burgers to Banks and beers now
bedecked in the rainbow flag companies
have to work a little bit harder to
prove just how virtuous they are glamor
magazine has chosen to make Logan Brown
as pride month cover star I'm a pregnant
trans man and I do exist he said no
matter what anyone says I'm living proof
let me proof of what
Logan is living proof that biological
women can get pregnant there's hundreds
of biological women do every single year
that's it that's that's all this proves
this is precisely where this movement
loses everyone with a shred of common
sense it's not about trans people it
really isn't most people watching this
have probably never even met a trans
person most people including me who have
just want equal rights and respect that
anybody who suffers from gender dysmoria
who genuinely believes they're born into
the wrong body this is about
increasingly hysterical campaign to make
us all believe the sky is green and the
grass is blue that anyone who disagrees
is a hateful transphobe and a bigot it's
a campaign that petrifies politicians
leads us to the remarkable position that
the two opposition leaders in British
politics now make statements like this
a woman can have a penis
Nick I'm not
I don't think we can conduct this debate
with
you know sorry indigenous no no it's
just no no I just
can a woman have a penis
well I've just answered that question
they can
um listen I've made it really clear that
if people
um uh the vast majority people will have
the same gender as their biological sex
but a small number one so a woman can
have a penis well quite clearly
quite clearly a woman can have a penis I
mean that happened before it went away
and I spent the whole week I was in
France mulling over the answer and
concluded it was a completely stupid
thing to say wasn't it can you imagine
if I'd said 10 years ago that British
politics would pivot on the question of
whether women have penises or that the
most terrifying question in the world
would be what is a woman
documentary of that name what is a woman
calmly eviscerates his absurdity by
allowing the people to advance the
loneliest arguments to tie themselves in
their own knots
please if one person could tell me what
a woman is
why not for women we ask you to leave
what is that a woman is not anything in
particular there is not one particular
thing it could be many things to many
people some women have penises right
some men have vaginas women only know
what women are are you a cat no can you
tell me what a cat is
do you want to tell us what a woman is
I'm a biological woman that medically
transitioned to appear like a male I
will never be a man the interview is
over let's turn off the cameras excuse
me I just wanted to know what is a woman
and you're not gonna find out
well that documentary was posted to
Twitter at the end of last week so it
could be seen far and wide for free to
Mark its anniversary and a sign of these
fevered times it was censored for the
crime of misgendering
misgendering
well Twitter's new owner Elon Musk
personally intervened and then
recommended the film to his gazillions
of followers and in a second sign of our
times the Tweet promoting the film has
now been viewed
172 million times so the biggest film in
the world right now isn't Little Mermaid
Spider-Man well it is Fast and Furious
it's what is a Woman by Matt Walsh which
I think shows the level of sheer
exasperation there is at this Relentless
campaign to subvert reality and Bully
anybody who refuses to go along with it
but the avoidance of Doubt a woman is an
adult human female that's it beginning
and end the percentage of women with
penises
is zero
well does that even lies Matt Walsh the
filmmaker of the year right now uh joins
me Matt well congratulations I mean the
biggest movie in the world
thank you I appreciate that uh it's been
a staggering week for you I mean it was
a great film when I watched it
originally uh because it just basically
kept asking the same question I've been
asking on the show for the last year uh
but it's a question which flummox is
everyone from Supreme Court Justices to
male politicians here to anyone you care
to think of in public life
um when you put it on Twitter and then
it got suppressed and then Elon Musk
intervened what was your feeling about
that whole process
well when they first when they first
decided to censor it it was kind of this
feeling of well well here we go again
because this is what we're used to from
uh from Big Tech it's you know every
single big Tech platform is run by the
radical far left and especially on this
particular issue
um they they don't want you to talk
about it they don't want to acknowledge
there are basic truths that aren't
allowed to be discussed we were just
demonetized by YouTube on misgendering
grounds you know just a couple of weeks
ago we thought that Twitter would be
different under Elon Musk and then they
kind of pulled the rug out up from under
us and at first for me it was sort of
this okay well I guess Twitter is the
same as all the rest of them until Elon
Musk as you say intervened and uh next
thing you know where there are
resignations and all these sort of thing
happening happening over at Twitter in
their uh in their brand safety
department
um which which makes it clear that uh
that no in fact Twitter is the one
exception it's the one major big Tech
platform where free speech is allowed so
I was I was happy that of course how it
worked out but also that this film on
top of dealing with the um with the
gender their issue also could you know
succeed in really a victory for free
speech I think it's a really important
Victory Free Speech because if if it had
gone the other way and Twitter had
decided to keep this film censored then
that would set a really dangerous
precedent I think for uh all the other
plots yeah talk about a question Elon
Musk said this in reply to someone who
tweeted him this was a mistake by many
people at Twitter talking about the
suppression of your film it's definitely
allowed whether or not you agree with
using someone's preferred pronouns not
doing so is that most rude and certainly
breaks no laws I should know that I do
personally use someone's preferred
pronouns just as I use someone's
preferred name simply from the
standpoint of good manners however for
the same reason I object to Rude
Behavior ostracism or threats of
violence is the wrong pronoun or name is
used which I think is a pretty
reasonable position I mean is that a
position you would share
not I mean I don't personally share that
position I'm not going to use preferred
pronouns I'm going to use the pronouns
that are that are accurate and I just
reject the concept of preferred pronouns
uh you know you can prefer whatever
pronoun you want or whatever adverb or
you know noun you want but that doesn't
mean that I have to use it you don't get
to put words in my mouth however uh the
the position that Elon Musk has on this
is uh you know it's position a lot of
people have and at the very least it
respects free speech so this is what
he's going to do but you can say what
you want because you can't force someone
else to share your perceptions that's
what the preferred pronoun thing is all
about yeah you know they're trying to
not only put words in your mouth they
want you to affirm their perception of
reality and uh the idea that we would be
forced to do that either legally or even
according to the um terms of service of
a big Tech platform it's just uh it's
just insane what it is and of course the
argument that uses was offensive but of
course the whole point of free speech
really at its Hearts is that you should
be allowed to offend people I mean
that's the point of free speech it's not
that everyone agrees with each other
it's that you should be able to
vehemently disagree or be offensive or
rude if you want and people should be
able to tolerate that because that's
what happens in a free Society with a
thriving democracy that believes in free
speech
yeah I and that is the importance of
Race Free Speech and like I said a lot
of this story is is about a victory for
free speech which is really important
but I also want to note that you know
what's happening here is on is on an
even deeper level because
um on the left what they're trying to
shut down it isn't just speech generally
and they are trying to shut down speech
but they're trying to shut down true
speech so it's not just speech it's it's
in particular basic fundamental truths
of life that they're trying to stop us
from saying and that makes it all the
more uh dangerous and egregious I mean
your issue with YouTube was they
demonetize the effects of You by saying
that you had misgendered Dylan Mulvaney
who's this transgender influencer that
of course has created Bud light's uh
Revenue by taking part in a PR stunt for
them which enraged the the core
customers at Bud Light
um what did that whole thing tell you I
mean hey what happened to you guys in
terms of of the way YouTube responded
but also about what happened to Bud
Light
yeah I think it shows that people are as
far as Bud Light goes people are
exhausted by this uh the left you know
they were able to run roughshod over the
culture in in Western culture generally
for years and I guess they assumed that
there would never be any there'd be
never be any pushback and they kept
going and kept going until normal people
just finally had enough of it and I wish
we had enough of it much sooner but uh
but it but at least now finally that's
uh you know a line is being drawn and I
think one of those lines is when you're
trying to get people again trying to
force them to affirm and celebrate
something that's just not true uh at a
certain point I think it's uh it's just
it's too far for the average person
that's what we're seeing now this is not
display what the left says you know this
pushback against uh LGBT pride and
against the transit of kids this is not
some Sinister right-wing well-funded uh
conspiracy this is really a this is a
Groundswell thing this is this is
Grassroots these are just normal people
who had enough of it yeah I completely
agree and then Dylan Mulvaney's case I
mean Dylan Mulvaney identified as a gay
man until last year and a lot of women
have been genuinely outraged that Dylan
Mulvaney has been putting out these
videos effectively mocking women
actually if you look at them and that's
been my problem with what Dylan Mulvaney
has done so dilemma already can can call
herself whatever she wants I don't care
um what she can't do I don't think is
make millions of dollars mocking the
concept of Womanhood when until last
year she identified as a as a gay man
and it's clearly a biological male
and it's also the irony that we hear so
much about the dangers of appropriation
these days uh even when it comes to
things like Halloween costumes where
someone is clearly just having fun and
they put on a Native American Halloween
costume whatever it may be we're told
that that's uh that's horrifically
racist and it's it's demonizing and it's
a caricature of the person here well
well that's that's exactly what Dylan
mavania is doing he's uh he's making a
caricature of Womanhood
this cover of Glamor magazine involving
uh Logan Brown who is a trans man
appearing to be a pregnant man on the
cover but of course Logan Brown is a
biological female uh so it's actually a
pregnant female that we're looking at on
the cover when a a magazine a
mass-market mass selling women's
magazine like glamor does that to
celebrate pride month what does that say
about where we've come to as a society
well I tell you one thing it actually
says it makes the the opposite of the
point they're trying to make because the
point it actually makes is that women
are still women no matter how they
identify I mean I read that article and
they're making a big deal about you know
Logan Brown was saying well yes uh I
exist I'm I'm pregnant this is this is
real I know it's blowing people's minds
well no it doesn't blow anyone's mind we
know that you're a woman even if you cut
your hair short and you give yourself a
different name you're still a woman you
still have the biological function and
capacity of a woman so that's actually
what it proves is that these biologists
this biological identity is inherent
it's immutable
um you can't get rid of it you just are
who you are no matter how you identify
no that's not the point that we're
trying to make but to me that's that's
uh that's what it proves that even a
quote-unquote trans man can still get
pregnant proves that you know she's a
woman we've seen as I said Bud Light
we've seen the revenue collapsing after
the de la maldeni thing we've seen
Target a big supermarket chain in
America suffering similar problems after
really going very hard on Pride
merchandise in the children's
departments we've seen your film try to
be canceled and then bouncing back
within days to become the most watched
film in the world I'm getting a gut
feeling Matt the the woke worm is
turning the common sense is beginning to
win the day and it's because the
majority of people who've been silent
and been cowed into silence are
beginning to find their Collective
voices and acting
I think that's exactly what happened and
that's something that even when we were
filming was a woman which goes back you
know we were filming it in 2021 a large
part of 2021 and uh you know I can
remember going around the streets and in
various different cities and doing this
man on the street interviews with people
talking about these issues with them you
know what is a woman how do you define
Womanhood and people were just the
average person on the street was
terrified to even discuss the issue
especially on camera I think that if we
were to do that part of the film again
right now I think we would get
um a different kind of response I think
there'd be a lot more people willing to
talk about this because I do I agree
people are finding their voice uh it
everyone has always known that this is
that this is crazy the idea that Sexes
can be changed and all of that people
know that it's crazy but they've been
they've been uh you know cowed into
silence and all it took was just to
realize that you know it's okay you can
speak up and say what you know is true
and once that starts happening I think
it builds momentum and I think the left
is really worried about that yeah
sometimes if you want to know it's
raining just open the window and have a
look when it's raining and you'll see
rain
and the moment you start to deny that is
where the trouble starts Matt Walsh
congratulations on having this monster
film you're you're bigger than Spielberg
right now I'll take my hat off to you
really appreciate it thank you all the
best
well answer the next the Phillips
Schofield saga's dominated British news
for weeks is it time to stop I'll give
my verdict and debate that while my
panel next
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back and it is good to be back
uh the media scrutiny around this
morning presenter Phillip Schofield has
been Relentless since he stepped down
more than two weeks ago and sit down
into these with the son on the BBC he
talked about losing everything after
admitting an affair with a young male
colleague
I understand
how Caroline Flack felt
last week
if my
daughters hadn't been there
I wouldn't be here
who knew on the team nobody
well today the key member of his team of
course Holly Willoughby is co-host
return to this morning saying she feels
shaken troubled and let down
imagine that you might have been feeling
a lot like I have
shaken troubled let down worried for the
well-being of people on all sides of
what's been going on and full of
questions
you me and all of us at this morning
gave our love and support to someone who
was not telling the truth
who acted in a way that they themselves
felt that they had to resign from ITV
and stepped down from a career that they
loved
that is a lot to process
well we all know about stepping down
from jobs we love at ITV but there are
big questions left to answer over this
Scandal or is it time to say enough is
enough do you want to be discuss or was
a journalist Jenny cleeman talk to these
Richard Tice and Rosanna lock with my my
standing
but not for long like all standing she's
plotting and planning to seize the big
chair
um all right no comment well if you're
not you should be
um what's your taking all this and I've
been on for a week reading about it
obviously while lying on a sunbed and it
just reached a crescendo after Schofield
gave his interviews well I looked I've
known him a long time 35 years I wrote a
biography of Phillip Schofield literally
in the 90s
um and I looked to the guy and I thought
you are completely broken yeah and and
when someone is in that condition
um even though I felt that his
comparison to Carolina Flack was clumsy
and and he probably shouldn't have said
that he probably meant it he probably
did feel that he was genuinely what's
left I may as well kill myself what do
you think of the whole thing where are
we now with this story I mean the
question that you lined us up with was
should we still care about it is it too
far now I'd say it was too far a week
ago I was saying this when I sat in your
chair this time last week why why do the
public care about this I don't really
give two Hoots about it it's a
television show perhaps a bit reductive
I know it's representative of other
issues in society I know people are
interested but sometimes what's in the
interest of the public isn't what's in
the public interest Richard uh for me
Pez actually he probably was right to
give that interview because it
highlighted to everybody just how he was
feeling and I think that was the moment
at which actually people stopped
attacking him and focused on which I I
think is the right thing to focus on
which is the appalling incompetent
leadership and management of ITV which
is actually a seriously important
the one thing I know for sure a lot of
people at ITV knew about
the rumors about this relationship I
mean everybody knew at ITV right let's
be crystal clear that building was a
buzz with this for about three years
because three years ago the national TV
Awards in the ITV box the young man
concerned in mystery uh confessed his
undying love for Phillip Schofield
everybody knew that so this idea that
the whole management are basically going
we didn't know anything come on
um so that that proves my point that I
know is not true I mean she has presided
over an absolutely catastrophic
performance of this company the shares
are down 60 the dividends down Ford have
said she's being summoned to the select
committee and yet the non-exec directors
they're saying nothing the company said
nothing at the corporate level you know
about this and Dame Carolyn uh God bless
her she was the CEO and I left Good
Morning Britain and they put me in a
position where I had to either apologize
for disbelieving princess Pinocchio or I
had to leave immediately there was no
inquiry for me it was just like you
either now publicly apologize the
disbelieving Meghan markle's lies as it
turned out or you have to leave
immediately so I took the leaving
immediately option uh but what's
fascinating is two days after that after
I'd left
uh the Telegraph newspaper runs a story
that says that Meghan Markle had written
to name Carolyn on the Monday night
before I left on my Tuesday demanding my
head on a plane nobody thought to
mention that to me and had they had done
I wouldn't have been so Hasty in leaving
I would have said I'm not leaving
because some princess tells you to make
me leave right so now to bring it up to
full speed now the same game Carolyn
McCall has repeatedly said in public
that it had no bearing on the decision
to force me out that is a lie if you're
watching Dome Carolyn that's a lie you
know it's a lie I know it's a lie I
don't want an ongoing fight with ITV I
had a great time at ITV although I
didn't even get a carriage plot when I
left not even a carriage lot but 15
years not even a clock yeah but what
were you I mean what would you do with
the clock if you could work in a factory
somebody gives you a clock right I
didn't even get a thank you right at
least Felix Schofield got 30 seconds of
Doma earlier on a Monday thanking him
I've done nothing I trebled the ratings
my point really is
my experience of interview management
from the top down is that when it suits
them they'll lie through their back
teeth
secondly that the way they handle Talent
is morally schizophrenic
depending who you are and how important
they think you are to the firmament at
any given moment or how important your
agency is in the case of Phillip
Scoville and Tech so on people like that
Holly Willoughby
um they look at all those things they
make moral judgments based on that kind
of stuff that's where they lose me it's
not consistent there's no concern right
the thing is that will all come out
because there's going to be an inquiry
yeah and I think that's a really good
thing that there is going to be an
inquiry I think if this had happened on
the BBC they would have had to have
called an inquiry a long time earlier I
do think though that there is a there
has been a Feeding Frenzy which has been
spurred by some people who have a
personal beef or maybe jealousy of both
Holly Willoughby and Philip Schofield
that has allowed this story to have a
momentum to go on and on in a Relentless
way that perhaps it doesn't necessarily
well again look Phyllis Schofield made
quite a lot of enemies it's not a secret
I know quite a few people well mutual
friends who can't stand it right and
they really can't stand and they made no
signal of it Amanda Holden Eamonn Holmes
people like that they can't stand the
guy right
um so that was not a secret uh but I
wrote a piece the chalk and cheese
though peers as you know very well you
know like some people I prefer to be a
pleasant surprise and a bitter
disappointment my my argument about the
ITV daytime firmament was that so many
of them were just total fakes I wrote
this piece for the sun when this first
broke 10 days ago that the whole thing
is basically fake right they're not real
people a lot of them so they'll say to
your face I love you I love what you do
you're so fabulous peers and then behind
your back you hear but almost
immediately that they despise you on
can't wait to get your job it's like
it's a whole edification thing is it a
lot of broadcasting like that it is uh
yes yes it is yeah it is and it's a lot
of bosses telling you you're wonderful
you're wondering
you normalize lying and that seems to be
what's happened here is that the lies
went on and on you know if something is
fake it's essentially a lie and that's
going throughout the whole organization
can Holly really not have known
and in Her speech today reminded me
we've got a bit of a here I think
let's have Holly again
imagine that you might have been feeling
a lot like I have shaken troubled let
down worried for the well-being of
people on all sides of what's been going
on I knew what reminded me of it was
this
Kessler my co-host and partner of 15
years
was fired today for sexual misconduct
stay strong first and foremost I want to
offer our sympathy and support to the
women
we are devastated that this happened on
our watch and our hearts are with you
and to you at home I understand how you
must be feeling because I and the whole
team here at the morning show are
feeling the same way
shock
disappointment
disbelief she's throwing me under the
bus
well
I mean apart for the white dress which
was a good touch the Angelic look uh no
I I like Hollywood a bit she's a good
friend of mine I've known but let's go
over a long time right
um
I like Holly and I don't she's in an
impossible position yeah right she had
to come she had to come back
contractually and do and do what she did
um it's just again I wrote in this piece
like that the the speed with which
people go from Heroes in this game right
where Charities are falling over
themselves to use them to their friend
people they think of their friends at
work no here's a message they're not in
most cases in most cases they will Chuck
you under a bus and into a grave as soon
as look at you while simultaneously
ringing the bosses trying to get your
job right it's just what the nature of
the Beast is it's ruthless it's horrible
and we've seen it laid bare at his worst
but it was out of my question I guess we
started with this didn't we
at some point you've got to you've got
to move on from this unless something
comes out unless the young man concerned
in this story that fully discovered the
affair with as he comes out and
contradicts Philips Global's version of
events or somebody else comes out with
new Revelations what else do people want
Villa Schofield is a broken guy yeah
he's not going to work on television
again almost certainly he's lost
everything in his life yeah uh I don't
know what more the being mob on Twitter
won from Phillip Schofield that he
hasn't already lost and that was what
was so evident from that interview he
was an empty husk and I agree with you
it's clumsy the Caroline Flack
comparison but I remember watching her
documentary where she say she used to go
home after recording her shows and just
read all the tweets and all the comments
and feel empty and emptier and it
reminds you that yeah Showbiz people
presenters they're overpaid it's a
lovely life but they're also human and
it really does kill someone's soul to be
attacked like that mercilessly day after
day but I will say this have the ratings
of this morning ever been higher than
they were this morning I don't know
we'll find out I mean the problem for
Hollywood be if they were gigantic for
the first half a minute and then plummet
um I mean we'll see look it's not a
funny version she's obviously being a
very tight it's tough it's difficult
you're in an arranged marriage of these
situations I was in one myself suddenly
you're divorced right it's very you know
um hard to maintain and when you say
what what what do people want they want
her destroyed they want the show Ax and
there are some people who have you know
like proper professional beefs or who
want the job and are going to keep on
going as soon as you know when the
results of this uh inquiry and I'm not
saying they're all going slightly nuts
but this was the the boss of this
morning uh Martin Brazil uh who's a good
guy uh and from my experience but this
is how you reacted this morning to Sky
News
say it was toxic I've always found toxic
is aubergine do you like aubergine
do you is there a toxic work do you like
aubergine because I don't like aubergine
it's just a personal thing is there a
type of work environment that this
morning
I've heard of what about is that's a new
one if somebody mentioned it might be an
emoji a reference I don't think we
really want to go there but um these
situations do send everyone slightly
nuts this this probably goes quiet until
the inquiry comes out and if the inquiry
finds that actually the management and
the leadership and the board knew about
this then I think the whole pack of
cards comes down and it's a start again
you know the hardest problem for Holly
Willoughby will be who to replace him
with because Paul Susanna Ray she's been
through about 15 blokes now and none of
them none of them live up to me and
that's a heartbreaking heartbreaking
moment hard act to follow yeah
[Laughter]
let's throw your face you're all like oh
really
it's a joke remind you when one of them
was Aleister Campbell you can quite
understand it my God talk about
cratering the audience maybe could you
not do it uh actually because she lead
it and then have a sort of guest host
each week yeah that's what she's doing I
think
it's a fascinating scenario I just think
probably most people in the country now
if not the wider world of just bulb with
it the board short of a new bombshell
move on
don't be a thing yep yep I think so uh
thank you back well you're gonna hang
around right uh answer the next I'll
speak exclusively to The Scholar Noam
Chomsky what a Segway from this morning
to Noam Chomsky we'll be talking about
the war in Ukraine the possibility
entropwich and the White House and the
world moving closer to its end on
doomsday that's a big pivot you've just
made me do there in the gallery but
we'll be back with gnome Johnson in the
end of the world
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to peers organized sensor
is it me or is politics is not the world
gone completely nuts the US president
can barely walk and talk the former
president has been indicted on criminal
charges a British prime minister had a
short a shelf life and a lettuce
Vladimir Putin launched a war in Europe
and thinks he's winning it well Noam
Chomsky is a linguist philosopher of
fiercely outspoken political activist
and honestly one of the world's great
political Minds I spoke to him at length
a riveting interview on Trump's return
the state of the world and on the end of
the world
pleased to be with you I wanted to start
by asking you there's a famous Doomsday
Clock based on what a lot of experts
perceive to be the moment the world
basically ends that clock is now heading
towards the dreaded midnight you're 94
years old you've had an extraordinary
life you've seen lots of things not
least world wars
um what do you think about the state of
the world right now and are we right to
be perhaps concerned that doomsday is
on its way
well the Doomsday Clock Was
said in 1947
shortly after the
bombings of Hiroshima Nagasaki at that
point it was Seven Minutes to Midnight
later the analysts abandoned minutes
altogether moved to seconds to now said
at 90 seconds to midnight
for good reasons we're now facing
questions that have never Arisen in
human history they will have to be
answered soon or else
were essentially finished
one of course is the threat of nuclear
war which is growing both in Europe and
in Asia the other is the inexorable
March stewards climate destruction we
have a couple of decades in which to
deal with it
methods are pretty well known if we
don't pursue them we will pass
irreversible tipping points and there
will be a steady decline to
undescribable catastrophe that's where
we stand now I mean I would add a third
of that potentially purely based on what
Professor Stephen Hawking told me and
what turned out to be his last
television interview which when I asked
him what was the biggest threat to
mankind he said when artificial
intelligence learns to self-design then
that's it
um there are some experts out there in
the world of AI who believe we may be
approaching uh that eventuality what's
your view of of AI and that threat
I think that's mostly science fiction I
mean in principle it is possible to
reach what's called Singularity to reach
a point where AI might move on
independently but this is such a remote
contingency that I really don't see any
it doesn't seem to be worth considering
very seriously especially when we think
of the imminent catastrophes that are
quite real on the on the catastrophes
that you outlined taking the first one
of nuclear war
how close do you think we're getting to
that potentially happening with this war
in Ukraine in other words if Ukraine
with its offensive was to push Vladimir
Putin back if it looked like back home
in Russia he may be losing the war or
he's even driven out altogether
do you think he's potentially the kind
of person who might actually use a
nuclear weapon to seize back initiative
it's conceivable uh tactical nuclear
weapons have apparently been at least in
Belarus the West is taking a
ghastly Gamble
they're assuming that if
Russia faces defeats which
does not look too imminent but if they
do
that Vladimir Putin will
pack his bags and slank Away silently to
Oblivion or worse and will not use the
weapons that everyone knows he has to
escalate the war up to the point of
attacking NATO supply lines in Western
Ukraine in which case there's growing
confrontation with NATO that once you
step on the escalation ladder it's very
hard to stop so it's possible okay let's
move to another issue I think we have
more common ground on Free Speech it
seems to me has never been under more
ferocious attack in the west than it is
right now why is that and what do we do
about it
there definitely is an attack on freedom
of speech even freedom to read in the
United States
we're on the Sanders running for
president as he just announced has
imposed regulations laws in Florida
which make it illegal to teach a
authentic American history you have to
teach a kind of History which glorifies
the United States nothing about what
actually happened this is happening in
Republican legislatures around the
country that libraries are being forced
to throw out books there's
laws passed to say their topics are not
allowed to talk about well he would
argue I mean to scientists with argue
I've interviewed him he would argue that
he is focused on things like critical
race Theory which he feels is
inappropriate for teaching young
children he thinks that gender ideology
should not be taught to young children
and it has a lot of support a lot of
Floridians agree with him about this
critical race Theory what is critical
race Theory does anybody know
critical race theory is a slogan
invented by the right wing and the
person who invented it Christopher Ruffo
has been very open and Frank he says we
just use this as a way to refer to
everything we hate
if you want to know what critical race
Theory actually is it's a small academic
discipline which suggests which
investigates systematic elements of
racism racism in American Education they
certainly exist to never reach the
schools schools wouldn't even know what
it is this is invented by the right wing
exactly as rufo stated to refer to
everything we want we hate and want to
destroy like teaching American history
like
teaching gender issues we hate that so
we'll call it critical race Theory who
has been for you the best American
president of your lifetime and who's
been the worst in my lifetime
if they are Franklin Delano Roosevelt
and the worst too much competition I'm
afraid
I know you know you're not a massive fan
of Donald Trump how do you feel about
him running again no
if he runs again it'll be a disaster for
the world
for many reasons
for one thing Trump as you saw during
his first time is dedicated
actually his he has two commitments one
commitment is to himself he's in a
megalomaniac psychopath all that
concerns him is me the other commitment
is to serve corporate power and great
wealth abjectly is one legislative
achievement was a huge gift to the tax
gift to the ultra wealth Ultra rich and
the corporate sector nothing else
but he is a major climate denialist he
denies the global warming is taking
place he wants to maximize the use of
fossil fuels including the most
dangerous of them
and to eliminate regulations which might
mitigate the catastrophe that's a death
sentence for the human species if we
knew this was going to be our last day
on Earth I asked Professor Hawking this
actually I said how would you spend it
and he said he would get his family
together
he would play Wagner very loudly and he
would drink fine champagne
if you knew it was all about to end how
would you spend your last day
I would get my family together but skip
the rest
[Laughter]
uh pleasure to talk to you so fascinated
talk to you for hours
um would you like your legacy to be if
you could write your own heading on your
own Tombstone here lies Noam Chomsky he
or would you like the rest of that
sentence to say
he tried his best
I think that's that's absolutely correct
and your best was extremely good and is
extremely good I'm josky thank you very
much Dave for joining me I appreciate it
thank you very much
well it was a much longer and really
fascinating wide-ranging interview you
can watch the whole thing in its
entirety on the Piers Morgan uncensored
YouTube channel the fastest growing news
channel of his kind on YouTube in this
country right now at one point in 1.2
million subscribers so join the party
and watch content like that full
interview with Noam Chomsky I'm since
the next Britain's media regulator
system team no action over one of the
most complained about moments in recent
TV history a Bridgeton star's verdict of
the king's coronation balcony was
terribly white is it a terribly wrong
decision
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
coming up on the talk Rishi sunak says
his plan to stop the boats is working as
he announces two more barges to house
migrants Ollie Willoughby returns to
this morning after the Phillips
Schofield Scandal saying she feels let
down and apple announces its first new
product in almost a decade find out what
it is at nine o'clock
let's talk about ruthless television oh
I've got some stories oh maybe I know a
book called toxic TV toxic TV
um so when I worked in newspapers it was
always a bit more honorable they'd stab
you in the chest journalist not in the
back although there's been a few sneaky
ones recently I'm joined by the
journalist and author Jenny Clement
again and talk to you presenters Richard
Tyson Rosanna Lockwood
um let's remember never get mad just get
even that's my uh my key life philosophy
very Sicilian like that
um
the whole interview is really riveting I
mean literally he's in his mid-90s one
of the great minds but Rosanna he did we
pondered this question if you knew it
was the end of the world he clearly
thinks this might be heading our way if
you knew it was the last day what would
you do I'd keep it uncensored peers oh
my God I like that I like it Richard a
lot of champagne yeah a lot of shampoo
anything else with the champagne well
your family your friends ideally but
just a lot of champagne forget the
cheese just oh my God cheese Jeremy what
are you saving your waistline I would uh
go and listen to lots of loud live music
and drink a lot of champagne as well I
think I'd fly to Club sank on sank in
Santa Fe with about 50 mates maybe a
couple of family uh I might include my
kids
um Club sank on saying magnum's a
Roseate sea bass off we go dancing on
the tables uh cigars Brandy death wasn't
it
that's the way to go isn't it isn't it
um interesting character though I mean
when you look to this take presenter of
the ways the world may end yeah quite
interesting very uh I was quite
surprised that he didn't think AI was a
threat that it could be I think he's
wrong about that yeah I hesitate to
correct an intellect of that brilliant I
think he's underestimating the threat of
AI I think AI is the biggest existential
threat right now to the world but it's
funny the people you speak to Jaron
Lanier is another Great Brain on
artificial intelligence and he says it
isn't as big a threat as you think
because when humans invented the car the
car can go faster than a human but that
doesn't mean it's better no but if a car
learned to self-design when shave Elon
Musk continues with his trajectory of
self-driving cars and so on if it if the
Machinery inside it computers start to
be able to think for themselves they
probably would just kill all the humans
right this is the problem with AI is
that actually they think like robots
right yeah but if you give them human
deviance if they're morally corrupted by
humans training them to be morally
corrupt and they don't care they'll
actually think that we humans are
pointless supportivist exactly I mean
that's the point if computers can think
uh in a in such a way and develop at the
point they don't care then that's a much
greater risk frankly than the risk of
nuclear war that troubled uh no more and
you don't even have to I mean they're
already teaching themselves new
languages if you can get an AI to
bioengineer a medicine it can also
bioengineer a chemical weapon of course
it can bioengineer a virus you know and
we're actually quite close to that I
mean I think it's very good that we're
having these discussions now about about
regulation that is a positive thing
before we're quite there but yeah I was
really surprised that Noam Chomsky was
so relaxed about he said it was like
science fiction it really really isn't
people thought pandemics was science
fiction yeah I mean look we've been in a
way since World War II as a world we've
been quite closeted historically
comparatively right I mean it's actually
statistically even now the safest time
to ever be alive people that there are
fewer Wars people are living a lot
longer there's less child poverty
there's more uh more cures for disease
and so on so it's actually a great time
to be alive it doesn't feel like it
because of social media so social media
have been around during the days of the
plague trust me it wouldn't have felt
great anxiety levels may have been quite
High
um but yeah I mean the other thing I
thought was interesting about Chomsky
was his assessment of Putin and Ukraine
which is really the great unanswered
question if Putin if it's
counter-offensive that's about to start
we think goes on and put him really
looks like he's starting to lose and
some of these mercenaries he signed to
do the fighting turn on him what does he
do I mean a corner of Vladimir Putin is
a dangerous thing the truism that
strikes me most about you know I'm
deeply interested in Russia and I've
studied it a lot is that the most
dangerous thing to come out of the
pandemic was Putin was left alone in a
bunker with nothing but history books
for two years and did something to his
psychology he's always been that way in
essence but this cornering him like that
but was interested that Chomsky said
um you know that sort of escalatory
thing that could happen and it worried
him when Chomsky has lived very much
through the Cold War we managed to
de-escalate I think we should listen to
him by the way do you do you hold your
glasses to look more intelligent yeah
occasionally I put
you do a bit of anchoring
I saw that going on
yeah Britain Ukraine what happens here
well actually I think the risk that
we're learning about of these private
militia private islands yes and how they
react both in you potentially in Ukraine
yeah but much more seriously within
Russia that could be the greatest threat
I agree who knows where that goes how do
you think it ends well the concern is
that that it's a zero-sum game and
Vladimir Putin who knows how far he will
go to to save face you can't we haven't
offered him a way out really the most
important thing to me about Ukraine is
that still more than half the world
basically sides with Putin understand
that and you understand Global
geopolitics large sways of this planet
do not think like we do here uh thank
you Pat surprisingly intelligent
conversation I I'm getting quite worried
about you all that's it for me whatever
up to as Rosetto quietly observed Keep
It Uncensored not just for your last
night either good night
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]